I'm going to give you an idea of what
a grammatical rule is by helping you to
formulate a rule to explain it.
Grammatical feature of English.
Before we do this,
I should bring up two more symbols
that some linguists use when analyzing
sentences. We've already seen
brackets which can enclose phrases,
another symbol as the asterisk which is
placed before sentences that are judged
not to be examples of a language
and another is the question mark,
but just placed before sentences
that are judged as questionable.
In the last lesson we saw that English
speakers tend to use subject verb, object,
word order in a statement like
you were there, but verb subject,
object ordering questions with
the verb be like were you there?
Let's come up with a way to describe how
English speakers ask questions with the
word be and sometimes with have compared
to the declarative sentence he has done
the work to has he done the work in both
examples it looks like the verb and the
subject invert the subject and the verb
seem to switch places when you ask a
question.
So let's try and formulate a rule using
the concept of inversion to describe the
situation in English and see how well
it applies English speakers in for the
noun phrase of the subject and the verb
to ask a question that works fine for
the example. Are you there? But how
well does it explain the second example,
has he done the work?
In that case,
our main verb is actually an auxiliary
with the past participle. It's as done,
but the whole phrase has done,
doesn't switch,
doesn't invert with the subject only the
verb has does so we don't find that we
ask has done he the work we asked,
has he done the work?
We realized that we don't
move the whole verb phrase.
We actually extract a verb from it's
verb phrase and place it before the
subject.
Now it doesn't look like we're inverting
anything because the subject now and
doesn't end up inside the verb phrase.
Instead it looks like we're actually
just extracting that one head verb and
moving it before the,
now with that in mind,
let's formulate a new rule
to describe the situation.
Let's say English speakers extract the
head verb from it's verb phrase and move
it before the subject.
Now to ask a question.
Now we have a descriptive rule that
seems to work for both of the examples we
have at hand.
So we're going to change our rural
slightly to produce similar sentences,
but the slight change we're making
is a move toward imperative logic.
Extract a verb from it's verb phrase
and move it before the subject.
Now this gives us a set of instructions
that if applied to the declarative
sentence produces the
question as it's output.
This be have asking rule will work pretty
well until we get to an example like
he will have done the work on Friday,
we'd expect will he have done the
work on Friday? But we get have,
he will done the work on Friday. These
rules are a work in progress. Then
I hope you now have a handle on the
basics of the grammar sentences and thank
you for learning with me.